all right good afternoon everybody and
thank you for for joining the session so
I'm Moe I'm the business development
manager covering the Middle East North
Africa and Turkey and so pleasure to be
here with this amazing set of panelists
I'm so excited to talk to you about
emerging markets why they matter I'm so
excited that I've been up since 4:00
a.m. today had nothing to do with two
screaming kids at the same time it's
just your excitement about about the
topic so I'll just walk you through a
couple of sides of why we are
particularly excited as Google play
about emerging markets before I invite
our panelists to join me on stage so you
know if anybody's been living under a
rock Android it's pretty big it's gonna
be growing quite a bit over the next few
years as well external projections
putting it at over four billion in a few
years time but what we're seeing is that
two-thirds of all new Android users are
actually coming from emerging markets
right so if you are looking at the next
wave of growth for you this is where you
need to be and these are the markets you
need to be investing in and you might be
thinking oh yeah that's great you know
we'll look at this in a few years time
but the opportunity is real today so we
looked at you know for our mayor based
developers we looked at where are you
getting your installs what are the top
markets and what we found was three of
the four top markets within which you're
getting installs are actually emerging
markets those are India Brazil and
Russia right and again you might be
thinking that's great you know we're
getting users you know but do they
actually bring in any money and the
truth is they do so again looking at the
top 30 countries why spend for our email
based developers we found that six of
the top 30 countries are again from
emerging markets and that's a rate
that's going to continue to go up so
we're seeing around 60 percent
year-on-year growth and spent coming
from from emerging markets so don't just
take it from me we have an amazing set
of panelists who are going to share
their experiences with you and hopefully
this will be a discussion that will get
you excited and leave you with some
ideas of how you can go after these
markets first up we've got sad who's the
CEO of many
thank you
hello everybody I've already passed the
first test cuz I thought was gonna stack
on those stairs also thank you google
let's clap it up for all Google account
managers everybody let's pack it up yes
get the energy up yet so we've wind
Miniclip one of the games that we're
well known for is April pool it's got a
very large audience we have 200 million
players every month engaging with our
content and one of the areas that we've
been working in particularly with Google
on quite strategically is able pool in
India it's probably not a territory that
many of you guys are focusing on and you
know the question would be is this
something that you should be looking at
I would say India is just one of the
emerging markets that you should be
talking about because we will talk about
others in a bit but one of the things
that we've definitely seen in in growing
our audience in India is just the
changes in consumer behavior just down
to something so simple as data plans
being far more affordable for the rant
for the standard consumer once that
started happening in India we saw a
massive massive uptick in users in that
territory because obviously we've got a
multiplayer game and when you've got a
multiplayer game it does take up your
data package but in India they really
responded well to that kind of simple
thing so we saw a lot of growth there
and I don't know how much you want to go
into around the monetization techniques
but we've actually seen some good
monetization there we're in the top
grossing charts in Android you could you
can you can see it for yourself and I
would say it's a very very meaningful
territory for us and it's in our top 10
of revenue generators now fantastic
thank you son next up we have Christina
with a VP of growth for memorizer great
language learning
[Applause]
hello everyone and thank you for Google
for the invite to share some insights
from memorize as well so memorize is a
language learning gap with 40 million
learners from more than hundred and
eighty countries all around the world in
terms of emerging markets although we
are based in London in Great Britain the
emerging markets especially Russia
Poland Mexico Brazil and even Turkey are
quite an important part of our user base
growth and it would be very exciting to
share some insights and things that we
have done an experienced in these
markets in the panel I think one of the
it sounds very trivial and
straightforward but one of the key
learnings so far has been that the more
you understand the markets the more you
understand the local need for learning a
language the the better you are set for
a correct value proposition and and
delivering the the promise that people
expect from different countries and it
can be something as simple as providing
a u.s. English course instead of British
English course for Brazilians or
investing in the right languages to to
offer fractions so small details like
that make it can make a big difference
and give a lot of guidance to to the
product teams and business as well so
really excited to be here today thank
you Christina
next up it's my pleasure to introduce
Anatole who's the CEO of game insights
thanks guys so we launched guns of boom
my first-person shooter for Android
round fourteen months ago but the story
behind its launch starts much earlier
like two years ago we decided to is
Turkey then Russia those emerging
markets as a testbed to validate the
game and in contrast to many t1 launches
like let's say let's try luncheon in
Canada first we use those markets and we
we discovered that we have to support
low-end devices we have to address
loading speeds device performance data
consumptions and I think that when
emerging markets first has allowed us to
enter many other markets including India
Brazil and other markets that are
growing at a huge enormous pace of
millions of millions of downloads so I
think the biggest success behind our
presence in Google Play was that we have
integrated a way for players to upload
the replays to youtube and all of those
emerging markets have creators and
influencers that are eager to share the
content locally and the spread of that
the like the spread of that is enormous
its thousands and thousands of daily
video uploads to YouTube and the
consumption rate is really high the
other essential part is tackling what we
call tier 0 pricing methods it's
creating the unique value proposition
for as tiny value as it gets for the
smallest price tiers out there so try
that do that and if you start with those
markets it's gonna be much easier to
scale globally so this has a couple of
key takeaways I guess we'll discuss more
thanks to Google wonderful thank you
thank you so much
all right so one of the first questions
that we get from developers is okay yeah
emerging markets that's great but where
do we start where do we go to for you
what was the decision factor to go after
these specific markets other than a
personal interest and just visiting
those markets I guess we saw a lot of
user growth in in India because of the
the the change in the data providers and
you know whenever we see you know users
growing that dramatically then you just
pay attention to it naturally we've all
got our analytics dashboards we can all
see what's lighting up and and what's
growing and so then you just kind of
naturally make that choice I have seen
from others and for us you know
especially for us amia based developers
I tend to think anything that's close to
home is a little easier as well so kind
of concentrate on but you know for us it
was the fact that we saw audience growth
in India as I'm sure many people have
seen across other emerging markets we've
also seen that growth in Brazil which is
why we're concentrating on Brazil as
well but if you see players downloading
stuff then you tend to kind of see what
you can't to try and you know further
encourage them to play your games it was
a similar experience for you follow the
users basically yes memories has mostly
grown organically so far and I mean
language learning is something that
people in almost every single country
tend to and want to do and you can focus
on so many different regions and areas
but for us it was one thing was sort of
organic chem new user numbers that we
obviously monitored but not less
significant factor was actually
subscriber user base so we we started
seeing trends where it was easier for us
to convert people and to to make them
memorize subscribers and we actually
then saw that okay if there is already
organic interest then what can we do to
actually improve the value proposition
and offering so that more people from
these countries have a reason to use our
app and
and their languages well even though we
started with us as the global launch
market we figured out that based on the
number of youtube uploads the game
resonates well with variety of north
markets so we had to tackle that we went
to Google Play team talk about those
markets went to local playtime events
learned more about it worked with local
creators so it was more of a discovery
process where do we put our efforts into
and especially like just optimizing for
those for some of those markets it might
not be really self explaining so it was
quite a learning curve but once we got a
couple of first countries in it get
easier so now I think if if we look at
eight top eight countries seven of them
in terms of monthly downloads emerging
countries for us so you see the user
growth somewhere you decide you want to
go after a market and you know typically
one of the things we advise our
developers is to actually localize for
those markets but localization can be a
quite broad spectrum right from just
translating text in game to all the way
to actually you know customizing
characters changing the enough
experience for different markets how do
you decide where do you want to be on
that spectrum well we I mean we we take
a we take an approach when we build the
games to try and reach the biggest
audience possible so I mean for pool for
instance everyone asks us what do you do
to culture lives or localize the game
apart from strings I mean it's not much
to cultural eyes if you think about it
if you know it's a stick hitting a ball
into a pocket right like that
that's the game and if you don't know if
you can't understand that going over Sun
yeah I mean but the point is if you
can't understand that globally then
that's going to be a difficult thing so
I think it's a bit unfair to ask us if
mean if you're making a RPG game or
maybe even a shooting game it might be a
different thing from terms of character
design and and and look and feel but for
us what we do see in localization and
then and that and what we've learned
over the last year is the things and the
promotions which tend to be popular in
in Tier one markets
necessarily translate into the merging
markets so we've seen just if you look
at our top in app purchases and the top
things that people buy it is almost
skewed in India compared to where it
would be in in a tier one market you
know in a tier one market they would be
more open to say a Gacha mechanic or
some sort of card pack or something
whereas in in in in the emerging markets
we tend to find that that the hard nosed
value for soft currency is what people
want they want to know exactly what
they're gonna get that's that's been our
finding and therefore our localization
efforts means that our promotions need
to cater for that and what we present to
that for that audience so that's where
we kind of sit on it yes we have paid
attention to different phases of the
user acquisition fund also there are
things that that you can do to be a lot
more relevant on Google Play product
page already so making sure that you
highlight things that that these people
from from the emerging market countries
are really interested in in you can
customize and sort of even the selection
of screenshots that you prioritize to
upload to the Play Store can can teach
quite a lot about what the users
appreciates from these countries and and
even making the content relevant so
memorize offers some tens of language
pairs and tens of languages to learn for
different users it's important to
understand what are the top ones to
Turkish people want to learn English
German and Russian so there's no point
in prioritizing Brazilian Portuguese or
or Spanish for them in order to actually
be super relevant and then also pricing
I think localized pricing is something
that has really unlocked opportunities
in different countries and where it can
make a big difference whether you you
get sort of half a percentage of people
to pay versus a few percentages of
people to pay so there are different
things to look at different stages of
the funnel and
optimization opportunities almost
everywhere sooner sir I think back in
January we ran one of the global events
which was the Lunar New Year and it was
kind of counterintuitive for us as a
local event that was launched globally
has performed as well as Christmas or
something like that in US but globally
so Lunar New Year was accepted by
everyone across the world so since then
every single local event we tried to
launch the globally would try to see how
that works like nowadays like we
recently rolled out local content for
India and it was well-received and I
think it's just because of the
collectible nature of things inside our
game people just want to try all of that
and they want to have all the costumes
all of the suits and want to try it all
so I think what it might work in
different ways for different types of
games so you have to try different
strategies so one of the things that you
obviously know is that purchasing power
varies between you know Tier one mature
markets compared to emerging markets how
do you cater for that how have you
thought about pricing when you've gone
actually after after emerging markets so
we we the first thing we have looked at
and tested quite a bit as well as to had
to see what is the sweet spot for
different subscription plans so it's
very easy to set up monthly three
monthly six monthly annual turns and
then see which one works and how to kind
of point that the good spot for the the
exact price that has the highest LTV and
and long term potential for for the app
so there's a lot of ways how to
experiment with that we have seen that
in some emerging markets people tend to
pick the cheapest and also the shortest
period subscriptions and then thinking
of strategies how to change that and how
to make the make the longer plans either
more affordable or more appealing and
and communicating the right value the
latest experiment we we did was was in
Mexico where we saw that there is a very
high proportion of users who instead of
going for annual price which is the
overwhelming preferred one for memorize
seventy percent of people from Mexico
actually picked a monthly price and
without doing anything else but just
increasing the monthly price
subscription fee a little bit we see the
shift towards people preferring the
annual suddenly so just experimenting
around that and really kind of
understanding the dynamics and the
delivers that you have with Google Play
tools as well can can give quite
interesting results for multiplayer
games it's much harder you know people
in the US might complain about lower
tier pricing in the other country but we
found a sweet spot you know players
might spend hundreds and sometimes even
thousands of dollars inside those games
so we figured out that giving out the
free kind of free cheaper starter packs
it might be worth 10 so even a hundred
dollars in some of those emerging
markets for much smaller price trilha
doesn't affect the game player game
economy that much so that's what we
opted in for we are creating those packs
that might be worth $100 in US and we do
one-time offers the regional offers and
given them one time at much much lower
prices and that worked well for us it
converts the users in those regions much
better and it's a great value for the
price so you have to find what you are
going to give away even for as low as 15
cents it needs to have the value and if
you try to compare that to us price it
might be just the one mad kid or one mo
pack but that doesn't sell well in
emergent market you have to create this
whole bundle worth 15 cents and we are
care with that because there is just so
much more things to explore and buy once
they get releases or seasonal content
new maps of things down the road so
we're totally fine givin away those
bigger packs initially for my slow
prices and with this do you not worry
about users from the u.s. switching over
to emerging markets and trying to take
advantage of those packs so since these
are only starter packs for new users
that you are able to acquire in the
first weeks it's not truly big issues
it's not like something that you could
get six months after you play the game
so that's how we managed to address this
issue so okay so I've got a question for
you Anatoly so what you're saying is you
do a Geo priced starter pack only but
then afterwards you just have standard
pricing across the globe well we don't
have some discounts and deals and things
like that but yeah well some of those
deals are kind of still pricey so we
don't really just the value of the
currency for those countries because
that's the question like you can truly
do that as too many people will try to
switch the region you know like other
platforms like PC platform selves or
dealing with that as too many players
are trying to buy the currency in
another region so we don't try to do so
we did that we did a whole geo pricing
activity where we change prices
completely I'm not gonna talk about that
question we're working with your team
right now and the or google play
engineers to try and resolve that that's
totally an issue if you change prices in
one territory and you've got community
people will go and try and game the
system VPNs are easy to get particularly
on this platform I think we need to
acknowledge that but it's too early to
tell with geo pricing for us right now
we we definitely saw an impact and
conversion we definitely saw people
spend more and for us it wasn't just a
starter pack it was across the whole
store and across the whole economy and
the reality right now is we're not sure
how that's affected LTV because we don't
know if people are doing more purchases
little and often or if they're still
buying like the one pack that they would
have done before but got more for it so
we really are still balancing that thing
but ultimately for us
I think the more important question is
how much are you getting as in terms of
the share of wallet for that consumer in
that region and from what we see in
these emerging markets we're very
encouraged by the fact that they are
willing to spend on entertainment the
fact that there is a willingness to
spend on ia P I think is a very
interesting thing because I I actually
think that emerging markets have got to
that step before even the Tier one
markets I think it took a long time for
free-to-play an IO P game mechanics to
really be seen as the de facto business
model here in in in Tier one markets
because if you think about it even 5-10
years ago we were having debates about
it's free-to-play the future we know it
is and no one really talks about that
anymore
but in emerging markets it's just they
don't even think about it they don't
worry about it so that's where I think
the Geo pricing stuff needs to be
considered around the share of wallet
for that consumer because obviously an
Indian consumer does not have the same
disposable income as a US consumer but
we've seen in China that change and
obviously you just have to look at the
kind of macroeconomic situation of some
of these countries and nations that that
will eventually change so we feel like
being there early making these steps and
understanding how the consumer behaves
is super important so that's what I want
to read off from that conversation our
games portfolio throughout the years
we've definitely seen some of the
markets transitioning from emerging to
much more mature markets perhaps
Southeast Asian markets that now have
many more payment methods and people are
just used to play that so I think it's
just a matter of time when we will see
more spending power in those countries
and like in a year or two we're going to
talk about those mark it's not as
emergent remember that breaks had China
in it as an emerging market here now we
don't speak about China so I nowadays I
called still Brits like Brazil Russia
India turkey Saudi Arabia I've heard as
well which is Mexico Indonesia
yeah we are seeing an interesting
correlation between like the performance
and business performance of certain
regions and markets and the deep
intention of people to learn a language
so an interesting case has been where we
interviewed a significant amount of of
our subscribers from from emerging
markets as well and then plotted against
data and we saw that for example Russia
and Poland and Turkey as well where
people can learn one level any language
for free and then have to subscribe the
the speed and the conversion rate at
very early stages of user onboarding was
the highest in countries where the
language learning intention tends to be
sort of less casual less kind of fun
hobby activity and more kind of need and
and serve aspiration and professional
improvement related and it's it's quite
fascinating because it gives a lot of
insights for for product and and tweaks
and improvements in in your own boarding
as well if you if you know how to nail
this this need versus yes we can match
the needs correlation so it's it's quite
useful to to understand the behaviors
and the motivators behind users of apps
for these purposes can I ask a question
of the crowd yeah if they're gonna
engage how many of you are act taking
active steps to do something in emerging
markets just one it's a decent
smattering but okay and and how many of
you obviously considering it because
you're listening but how many of you
think it's probably a waste of effort or
you don't have the resources to really
you know attack it
you can be honest you can be honest one
there's one person two three come on
there's no more that's er okay alright
so they actually everybody believes his
effort and I think actually the reality
of this is it's not a lot of effort
that's you know it's not a lot of effort
of because of to be honest what you guys
have done over the last few years I
think we've again Google has done a
great job and it's easy for me to say
this on a Google stage but Google has
done a great job in allowing us to have
the tools to really make efforts in
emerging markets so I think if you're
looking to do it and you haven't really
done anything because a few people
haven't it's just literally go in the
Google Play Developer console and you
can start that's very true
I know you're not allowed to say though
I mean I need to say yeah that's
obviously when I say it nobody will
believe me I'm paid to say it